[Music]
bro
what was it like for you joining the
texas chainsaw massacre
world like the the legacy of this uh of
this film
elsie
i mean it is pretty freaking cool dude
it's pretty freaking cool
um i don't know i love the original i
love horror this seemed like a perfect
freaking fit so
i was pretty intimidated um i'd seen the
original i was like this is an epic
horror movie how am i gonna do this
justice i felt a lot of weight in that
sense but it was super exciting i was
excited to work with elsie no likewise
what was it like doing the
the bloodiest of this this is a bloody
movie what is it like actually shooting
those scenes did it meet your
expectations was it different than you
thought it was going to be or was it
exactly what you hoped it would be yeah
so i've worked with fake blood before
and it sucks but whatever it was just
like oh you have a little bit of blood
on your hand whatever um you know and
then there were there's just a there's
some moments in this where we're just
head to toe covered in this like awful
sugar glycerin whatever blood um and it
looks really scary it feels awful but it
really added to the ambiance of making
this movie feel scary so i loved it how
long does it take to
wash
the blood off
is does it come off easy i had you know
we the trailers and each night i had to
go or each day whenever we'd wrap go
into the trailer
and do this the trailer showers which
aren't like the best i was like a
pre-wash before i get home to the hotel
where i do a full wash and then i'd wake
up in the morning and wash my hair to go
to set so i was averaging like three
showers a day
that's serious yeah i would say similar
for me although i would usually just
wait until i got to the hotel and then
it was very fun going through the lobby
and i would have this like black hoodie
on and my hair and hands would be
covered in this blood and like hey can i
get a coffee really quick thanks guys
and then yeah just shower for like two
hours
i'm sure after a while the hotel staff
was like oh that's just the that's just
those spunky little kids
what's the secret to nailing the scream
there's so much screaming in the movie
obviously i would think that you would
finish a take and then immediately just
like down
you know a quart of honey just to help
it throat from
from like callousing so i don't actually
remember the onset screaming as much as
like the crawling and the crying but i
remember doing some adr i did do some
temp adr
in my apartment like months later and it
was just temp and so i have everything
set up and they're on zoom and i'm like
ah and i'm screaming like help like
help i'm screaming and screaming and my
dog is at my feet asleep
and i was like this is good to know that
he will never
help me if i'm being killed
sarah i love that you did it in your
apartment and like have i assume you
have neighbors
being murdered later like just doing
some screaming and later they were like
we didn't hear anything which is also
good to know that if i'm screaming for
help no one's gonna help
oh my gosh what was it like having sally
make her big return in this one remember
me now
i'm the one who got away and i'm here to
make sure you
don't i think so cool and like i don't
know i don't want to say therapeutic
because it doesn't no spoilers but it
doesn't particularly work out for her
um
you know but it's very it's very cool
because i think you know handling kind
of a sequel
um
etc that this is uh it's so fun to have
like more elements of the original poke
through um and i also thought alwyn who
played sally was just so so so talented
amazing absolutely um so you did say
that it you know spoiler it doesn't work
out well it well for her it doesn't work
out well for a lot of people in this
movie
yeah that's a way to put
we won't it yeah
a lot of people are met with um i do i
am going to do a little a little spoiler
a little spoiler chat um so we can use
it once people have seen the film don't
i mean in the last few moments of the
film i just found myself screaming at
the tv
just drive
yeah don't put the windows down don't do
the autopilot just go
yeah of course it's it's you know it's
the karmic destiny of any horror film
there can there never be any semblance
of a hat at the end what is it like
watching yourself get decapitated
i was like yeah
i was like let's freaking go and i felt
like i was on the outside watching it
for the first time being like that's so
sick so i actually i don't know that was
the one time that i was like i love this
movie
that's funny oh my god
and elsie you're the uh you're the the
sole survivor of this of the entire film
this situation would you come back and
and do another one
you know years in the years in the
future or oh my god or next year i don't
know
it's gonna work
um
yeah i mean i'd love to see lyla just be
like in really good therapy like with a
support group like you know and then
leatherface just like
but
she's taking up crocheting something to
calm her nerves yeah and just like like
75 years old she's like oh yes this is
lovely and then
oh maybe it's maybe it's like leather
faces like um
you know sun or something like that
no face having kids yeah you never know
yeah
he's probably had a kid right he finds
love mythology yeah yeah of course yeah
that's a movie i would watch leatherface
finds love she fixes it it's like the
classic problem she finds him on tinder
10 years from now and is like you know
what i can fix him
you